so you sent me an email a few weeks ago
and I'm just going to read this and then
you can update uh what's what's changed
since then for you we'll just hop
straight into this on this one because I
think this will be interesting uh you
said hey Rich I messaged you on uh IG
back in November I don't have that
Instagram anymore so I I don't have any
reference for that but you said that you
messaged about you you and your
husband's prenup can you just kind of
give me a quick 10 second overview on
what you're asking
uh when we got married he would only
marry me on the basis that on the prenup
uh stated that if I was to divorce him
that he would get full custody of the
children and I'm unable to access any of
his
um you know
buildings or money if I decide to leave
them oh I don't entitled to anything
that's actually how marriage and divorce
worked uh quite a long time ago because
marriage was based on the acquisition of
in-laws and generally speaking the
father would get custody of the kids
um is that something that's enforceable
by law where you live no not at all we
have to go out of our way and pay right
for the money that's a better than the
point then all right so uh your 25 year
old female he's 27 you've been together
for seven years you live together have a
successful business together and you're
also three months pregnant
uh you say I write this message to you
as I'm Desperately Seeking advice with
some one sorry from someone with some
wisdom on the subject unfortunately I
know no one who has me my husband have
been watching RP videos for the past
year and a half I enjoy it and pretty
much agree with everything the culture
puts forward I was a proper Daddy's girl
and he luckily instilled all of the RP
material in Me growing up so it hasn't
necessarily been a huge adjustment for
me to making my marriage anyway let me
cut to the chase back in March my father
died it ruined me I left I'm not going
to say where you live and where you went
just to kind of keep it as Anon as
possible for you so you left where you
live and you returned home for three
weeks to deal with his death when you
returned a week later you were cleaning
and found a condom wrapper my heart sank
and went to ask
um his name is also starts with a d yeah
yeah okay so we'll call him d as well uh
so you went to ask him what is this he
didn't lie and told me that while you
were gone he uh had some fun with a girl
he never meant for you to find out and
was deeply sad that I had while watching
RP videos I did have to learn how high
value man has options and men as a whole
need variety I understood all this and
said to Dee in a conversation previously
look if you're going to step out I don't
ever want to know
okay
um after probably one week I slowly
warmed back up to him uh trying very
hard to deal with the grief of my dad
dying suddenly in the grief of my
relationship not being a Disney Dream it
was like I lost all my innocence when I
found out hard to explain but my world
view had changed dramatically
fast forward to September I was
beginning to feel suspicious about his
phone usage for the first time I decided
to take a look at his Instagram messages
that I found a conversation with one
girl which made my stomach turn I
immediately asked him what this is and
we got into a discussion about him
wanting to basically still uh
pound other people we'll call that I'm
trying to change the language for
YouTube
um I was unhappy about how he was going
about it I had the idea the opportunity
showed itself to him out with his boys
mainly then he'd take it move on AKA a
one-night stand explain that route it's
very difficult and once in a blue moon
how one night stands or even harder to
go through when you live with your wife
and live in such a small country I said
well it's not exactly meant to be easy
for you messaging girls on Instagram
them being able to talk to you anytime
and respond to stories and just in
general from connection with you is not
how I want you to go about doing this
okay so you had reservations about the
whole Instagram reaching out to girls uh
we came to a middle ground which
involved me compromising with him to be
able to organize his Shenanigans via
Instagram and his compromise was he
doesn't get to use emojis disappearing
messages turned on and no calling and no
WhatsApp okay so you set some rules and
boundaries for him even though it seems
like you're okay with him stepping out
it's been two weeks since then and to be
honest I can't get out of my head easily
I've allowed it for to be him to arrange
these outings I don't want to put it all
down to me being pregnant but it feels
like
feels like to me during that time I need
to be feeling 100 safe in our
relationship he's bear with me guys it's
just two more paragraphs he's assured me
that it's not even like he's seeing
girls he told me he actually hasn't
slept with anyone since I was away I
asked him why he told me that he said
that he could see that I needed to know
I trust he's able to engage with these
girls with no emotional connection like
most men and how it's just sex to him
other than this we're in a very we're
very strong couple but what I want to
know is me giving him the green light to
engage online with women a smart
decision I can't shake just how easy it
can be for him now I was so down for him
to do one-night stands so he could get
it out of his system have no connection
with a girl and for the girl to have no
connection to him I told him he's
underestimating how cuckoo women get
overseeing a married man and how they
can ruin relationships from showing
receipts and messages
uh they will get 100 jealous when he
posts me on his page and want to be his
girl he's a catch and I have no doubt
that there will come some time when they
try to sabotage a relationship find
myself seeking I'm sorry feeling anxious
whenever he's out now or even
questioning his plans I hate it so much
because for seven years I never thought
or felt these things I know I can't be
good for my pregnancy either me worrying
about him I also feel sorry for him
because he may be completely innocent
just out with a friends and I and he can
sense that I'm uneasy with it what do
you think about the situation am I being
unreasonable and not wanting him to
Source sightings via Instagram
would you recommend uh us do what would
you recommend us to repair the trust I
really have no one to talk to other than
you I look forward to hearing okay let
me close this
and switch this over
okay can you give me an update on what's
happened since then
so
uh the next day we actually had a
discussion and
he brought it to my attention that I'm
really trying to control this situation
and
um the things that my anxiety is coming
from
the control I I want in this uh example
like the Emojis and all these things and
he he just said to me Dan if you trust
me
you will let me
you will just trust me and know that I'm
never gonna want to hurt you and I know
how to deal with women
and distance myself from them in a way
that I'll never want anyone else like
you're my wife
and you have my child I want to be with
you and only you
so trust me and stop worrying
and where are you with that
I listened to him and
since our conversation I decided you
know what he's right
he's a grown man so
I'm just gonna trust that he knows how
to deal with these women
and that
if
he just knows what to do I guess but
soon after I told him that I messaged
you
and I read the email to him and I kind
of asked him like what do you think
should I be going on the live and he
said yeah sure I'm interested to hear
his take on things
as well
yeah so that's the update and we're
really good actually I've definitely
lost a lot of my anxiety around it I'm
not so suspicious of him anymore on
stress them know again hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out